[Music]
dino here
in the previous video in this series we
learned the basics of the api portal
in this video we will learn how to
publish apis to the portal to enable
other developers to find and use them
back to the apigee administrative ui i
can add apis here
to add an api we select from a list of
existing api
products we created an api product in
the previous video
this is the thing that external
developers subscribe to
in order to get keys to use the apis
so i'll select that previous api product
now it's asking for a spec this is an
open api
spec document that describes the api
being published here
the document includes method and url
path pairs
this spec is the thing that allows you
to generate interactive documentation
for the api
you can create that spec using any tool
or even apigee edge itself
i'll upload my spec here
back in the developer portal now we see
the api product great
clicking through i can see the api
documentation
the spec we use defines a very simple
api
with a single method path pair
get slash a very simple api
expanding that i can actually try the
operation
hmm it's asking for an api key
as a developer how can i get one of
those
to get a key a developer needs to sign
in
the portal implements a really simple
email-based
sign-in users provide their email
address
and then a click-through on the
verification link in the email that gets
sent to them
signs them in there's no password
as a developer once signed in i can see
my apps
i can see that i don't have any so let
me create
one name it
provide a description
clicking through i can manage the
products for that app
let's turn on access for that api
product
and save it and then
i can see my api key
now let's try the interactive
documentation again
paste in my api key
and it works
of course your api specifications will
be more complicated than this
but the documentation will render nicely
for you
for example here's what the api for
healthcare.gov
looks like in the apigee developer
portal
the portal seems like a simple website
but it's more than that
this is the digital connection between
api consumer developers and your apis
a key part of your api program
remember the apigee documentation and
the community are good resources to
learn more
till next time keep it digital